today's episode is brought to you by
square cash square cash is the best way
to pay people back you can pay your
friends back your family your co-workers
lizards anyone if a lizard has Square
cash you can do that um you could spit
you could pay do the lizard back sending
and receiving money is totally free and
fast and most fast and most payments
they they can be deposited directly in
your bank account in seconds that's
seconds so download the free square cash
app for iOS or Android pronto do it now
in fact hi guys what's up welcome to the
20th podcast the 20th episode of
congratulations the podcast I never
thought we'd make it to 20 but that's a
lie I kind of actually thought maybe
we'd make it to 20 but nonetheless
here's 20 and you know today I got to
tell you I woke up a little under the
weather
and I didn't I didn't I didn't feel very
good at all I was supposed to go to an
appointment and I had to cancel it and I
I did I cancelled the appointment and my
agents and my managers were angry with
me but I didn't do it I said I can't do
it I'm bedridden but I'm here still
recording the podcast for you my babies
cuz 20 can't wait the 20th episode can't
wait let's do this before we start this
is something I haven't done in the
podcast yet I always wait till the end
to plug my tour dates but when I do it
now because I feel like maybe some of
you guys turn the [ __ ] off and that's so
not fair now I know life is not fair but
I'm trying to [ __ ] gain the system
here Baltimore Maryland
June 15th first show sold out second
show I think that there's a little bit
of tickets left Atlantic City
that's sold out I think June 17th
Huntington New York West Palm Beach
Florida
I'm there the whole weekend June 22nd
Austin Texas coming up Albuquerque New
Mexico
Montclair Montreal that's how they say
at MOCA Nashville Tennessee Salt Lake
City Phoenix Arizona
Tempe Spokane Charlotte and Irvine those
are all the dates and I rescheduled my
Australia date hmm it to be in October
that end end man on fire the Netflix
special that I did is coming out in two
weeks on the 27th of June so put that in
your queue now here's the deal
everyone's going to say hey why don't
you come like I'm gonna do West Palm
Beach and I'm gonna do the show the show
is I'm gonna fly home and Monday there's
going to be a comment on either Twitter
or Instagram saying please come to South
Florida how come you never come to South
Florida now that's when I'm gonna get
blood met blood red mad I'm gonna get
BRM I'm gonna get blood red mad because
I was just there and see that's the kind
of thing that's gonna make me blood red
mad because just do do a little bit of
research you like a guy you want to see
him
don't be mad he's never coming to the
city when he's literally in your goddamn
city do you know I'm saying no I know
that's not just me I know it happens all
the time to different band members and
comedians alike but it also kills me
when somebody tweets you or somebody
like hey when are you coming to
Albuquerque New Mexico when you can
literally just type that into Google and
the first thing that will pop up is when
that artist is in Albuquerque New Mexico
I guess people want to feel connected I
don't know I just don't know I just
don't know so yeah I woke up a little
under the weather I don't think I sound
too bad though sometimes you wake up and
you sound awful and I woke up too I woke
up real late because I was trying to
sleep it off but woke up to about 175
texts hey how about when you wake up to
175 texts and you think that everybody's
dead in the world and then you check
your text and it's really just to group
messages just talking about [ __ ] one
of your friends you know
I wake up and I look at the I wake up
and I look at the text messages a
hundred and thirty five texts who's dead
no nobody just Jim made a mistake made a
typo and everyone's razzing him because
of the typo right hmm I had a show at
The Comedy Store uh maybe Friday and the
crowd was not good now it was fine it
was just annoying they were like they
laughed like hahaha and then that's it
usually the comedy stores off the hook
and everybody was doing it was having
this kind of a set nobody was bombing
but it was just not raucous how it
usually is and I wrote on Facebook or
Twitter both of them about how shitty
the crowd was and then I forgot that
when you do that then everyone is going
to text you that you know hey what
happened and nothing happened and it was
just annoying and I felt like one of
those [ __ ] idiots that just was
complaining on Facebook that shouldn't
have been um but yeah I don't really use
Facebook all that much at all actually
so that's something that's really
interesting to tell you guys because
that's not boring at all because it's so
not boring for me to say hey I don't use
Facebook that much so good job that I
did that good job that I mentioned that
right now so you guys definitely were
like oh cool that's really [ __ ]
interesting um but I've been hanging out
in LA it's been two weeks and I'm going
to Baltimore in a few days never been
there I'm playing the markets that I
haven't played yet but I'm gonna take
the wire tour I feel like there should
be every time I mention Baltimore to
somebody to let people go add the wire
though huh like that's their claim to
fame they should have a bus they should
have a bus tour to be like this is
Trayvon Barksdale's this was his stoop
and this is where that gunfight happened
and there you go that's what's going on
in Baltimore I don't really know what
Baltimore is I don't really know what
Baltimore has to offer um I'm going
there for tonight or one night but
that's it
I'm gonna do my show I haven't done an
hour in a long time probably since I
don't know [ __ ] man
over two months probably so I gotta get
together I gotta to get it together but
so I've been in LA and I go to this
coffee bean and I know that some of you
guys know this I know I talked about how
the coffee bean I used to run and then I
had to move I [ __ ] ran the whole
block and then I had to move and I don't
run the block anymore in this Hollywood
coffee bean but there's so many crazies
at this coffee bean dude and some of the
crazies are cool and some of the crazies
are not cool some of them you're like
you know you don't really want to talk
to all of them but it's right smack dab
in the middle of [ __ ] Hollywood and
there's one guy that's super annoying
but he's nice so whatever he's got a dog
that smells like [ __ ] and he smells like
[ __ ] too and he's always wanting to
[ __ ] talk and I don't want to and
sometimes he's like hey man can I bother
you and I just I'm like man you know
yeah it's like I'm just chilling dude
what's up and he's like whoa you think
I'm annoying ha and I'm like I mean you
know you are you know and he's like oh
yeah that's the kind of relationship we
have you know full head of hair um like
like literally like looks like a Marvel
villain like that's his gray full head
of gray hair and his dog looks just like
him and he's like hey can I do my
chicken dance for you and I'm like in my
head I'm like Knab but also yeah though
you know because what the [ __ ] is this
gonna look like the chicken dance so I
said yeah as I said yeah um he starts
doing the chicken dance already like
anticipated my yeah and was doing this
is the chicken dance Bok Bok Bok Bok and
was doing the chicken bent dance by the
way holding his dog on his leash and the
dog was like come on buddy
what are you doing just let me how about
that how about the fact that it being a
dog and then if you have an owner you
don't get to pick the owner how [ __ ]
up is that and I know what dog's life is
a dog's life and they don't really care
who they're with but dude imagine if you
were owned by a [ __ ] guy who does the
chicken dance at a coffee shop all the
time imagine that's your owner a guy
that's a Luna
Tec he says hey record this chicken
dance and I record it and then he says
you're gonna post that it'll go viral
and I say no I don't think so man I
might upload it now that I talked about
it on the on a podcast but that's that's
your owner dude like it fits you if
you're a kid and that's your parent you
can Lee you can be like all right even
as a 15 year old you can run away you're
crafty enough you figure it out but this
dog is on a leash the dogs with this
[ __ ]
he has to wait till like the guy goes to
sleep with the door open and then run
away but the dog doesn't even know any
better the dog were probably just chill
the dogs even know that the owner is so
[ __ ] up right imagine being a pet
[ __ ] tarantula in a cage and your
owner is just like some lunatic that
keeps [ __ ] in a jar on his [ __ ] desk
right you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] you're
a tarantula and you're [ __ ]
not only are you in a cage somewhere in
Monrovia but the owner has [ __ ] [ __ ]
in a jar and is dead that's that's
something that's out there you can
there's so many people out there there's
definitely a guy owns a tarantula that
keeps it in a case and he also keeps his
[ __ ] in a jar on his [ __ ] desk and
that tarantula can't do [ __ ] about it
feel bad for the [ __ ] tarantulas and
dogs you know what I mean so anyway this
guy's [ __ ] crazy he's definitely not
the only crazy person that's at this
coffee bean there's so many [ __ ]
crazy person says that this coffee bean
there's this other guy that has glitter
on his face all the time and open and
has a button-down shirt and he [ __ ]
opens it's open always he looks like
Billy Idol if Billy Idol was on you know
meth and had been on meth for like three
weeks and is like I gotta get off it
eventually but I'm gonna ride this out
for a little bit longer like he still
looks a little healthy but like knows
what he's doing but like also he's got
glitter all over his face and eyeliner
and looks like he's he doesn't know what
is in store for him even though he
thinks he's got it under control
real tight pants a little bit
fashionable sixty years old but insane
however insane and I know he's insane
because sometimes he has a guitar there
and he's like can I play a song for you
and I just say man I really
man I don't really that I don't like
when saying people play me at [ __ ]
music right so but he's always like kind
of friendly but you could tell like a
trigger like something could [ __ ] set
him off immediately so I'm I'm I get of
coffee I walk outside and as I'm walking
outside I hear him saying he's talking
to this girl and I hear him look at me
and say yeah that's right man keep
walking keep walking to me now I'm like
if this guy wasn't crazy I would have
said what's up is everything cool like
did I do something wrong like I'm sorry
did you did I offend you or what you
know do you think I'm someone I'm not
but however his brain is broken so I'm
not gonna like try and like use logic
with him so I'm just like you know what
I'm gonna let him have that [ __ ] because
he's an insane person because he is at a
cafe with his shirt completely
unbuttoned because his glitter all over
his face and you can't reason with
somebody who has glitter all over their
face don't give a [ __ ] who they are so I
just let it go and I sit down and I'm
having a coffee hanging out I'm about to
go do my show is just chilling keepin it
totally real
just [ __ ] relaxing the guy comes up
to me and I'm like here we [ __ ] go
[ __ ] and he says hey man can I
ask you a favor and in my head I think
no but with my voice I say sure and he
says uh um can uh I need to help like I
need to find a van that's what he says
he's to find a bit now I don't know what
he means like I don't know if he means
that there's a van out there that he
lost that he needs to find a specific
van or if he needs money for a van or if
he's just [ __ ] saying [ __ ]
because he's got glitter all over his
face so I'm like uh you need a van huh
he says yeah or like some kind of like a
Winnebago or some kind of a thing to
store eyford stop listening after that
and then I said I say well man look I
think I'm really the wrong guy to help
you find a van I don't know where vans
are and I don't know what you mean and
he says well I think I know how you can
help me
so instead of keeping on this having
this conversation I just say to him and
I say look man I'm not gonna help you I
don't want to and he says well why
didn't you just say that then
and I'm like as I say to him well there
you have it man
you know there you go took a few steps
but I just said it and he says well all
right man and he walks away like huffing
and puffing and I'm like I don't forget
this guy big he's mad at me for beat
this guy [ __ ] everything up and now
he's mad at me for the way I dealt with
it I didn't do [ __ ] I'm sitting here I
got my shirt on it least is not open all
the way so he leaves in the [ __ ]
pivots and walks back and he says hey
man is that your car out there and he
points to my car and I'm like for [ __ ]
sake now I gotta tell this guy where my
car is and I know he knows it's my car
cuz he saw me get out of it so I was
like yeah that's my car man and he says
is it true those windows are really
expensive and then it be a shame if
something happened to those windows and
I'm like it took me like 0.2 seconds to
realize that this dude is saying he's
gonna break my [ __ ] windows so with a
booming voice with like my [ __ ]
baritone [ __ ] I activate it and I say
hey [ __ ] are you threatening me
like that like a [ __ ] like like I
like I'm ready for action and he says
well no man of course I'm not threatened
you I just heard that those windows are
expensive but I'm not threatened you
threatening you and I said good
[ __ ] like that like some crazy
like now I'm the crazy [ __ ] guy and
now the managers out there and he
screams at this dude he's like
[ __ ] I told you not to [ __ ]
harass the customers get the [ __ ] out of
here and then the dude is like no no I'm
not trying to threaten I'm sorry I
didn't mean to do that I just will you
please mail my video tapes or mail my
mic tapes and managers like look man
I'll mail your tapes but I just can't be
harassing the [ __ ] customers I told
you not to get the [ __ ] out of here you
ok ok ok and I'm like what the [ __ ] this
guy's trying to mail video I don't know
what's happening dude I feel like I'm in
a [ __ ] Fellini movie I don't know
what's happening but I almost got into a
fight with a [ __ ] Billy Idol on meth
and I'm just trying to run this [ __ ]
coffee bean and drink the caffeine
before I get to the comedy
store and [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
terrible audience I mean I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on at this place
it's like between him and the chicken
dance guy it's like with the smelly dog
I'm like why what is it about
there's always [ __ ] crazy people at
coffee shops I feel like it's like
because it's like not that expensive and
they don't like crazy people don't have
money because they're [ __ ] insane if
they had a lot of money they'd buy [ __ ]
like [ __ ] you know stuffed animals
and plants they just special they don't
have money cuz even if they had money
they'd spend it on insane [ __ ] um uh
like glitter right um or chicken dance
lessons so like but I told the manager I
was like yo man I was like I like coming
to this [ __ ] place but yo it's like a
few too many flew over the [ __ ]
Cuckoo's Nest in this [ __ ] he's like
dude I know I try to be nice but it's
like it's really hard to you know it's
like a legal gray area where they're not
bugging anybody if they're not doing
anything like illegal then we got to let
him hang I'm like yeah man but I mean
dude and then and then I told the guy
the chicken dance guy what happened with
that guy and he's and he says to me all
that guy's crazy
um I mean how crazy you have to be if a
crazy person thinks you're crazy
oh the guy who wanted me to record the
chicken him doing the chicken dance on
my phone for me to keep told me that
another guy with glitter on his face was
crazy what the [ __ ] happening to this
world it's actually kind of sad now that
I think about it but there's all sorts
of crazy [ __ ] there like some
lady came up to me that looked like the
[ __ ] lady on the on the UM she's
there all the time she's wearing only
wears a robe she was a robe
she was a robe to this place to the
coffee bean and she [ __ ] looks like
the woman on the card on the on the hall
on the cards that you get at Hallmark
that the lady with the sunglasses and
the you know what I'm talking to you
know what I'm talking about I feel like
her name's May or some [ __ ] and the card
it's like a style of card with oh and
she's always on it
and she's like some bitter old lady
that's what she'd this lady looks like
and I was just sitting at a [ __ ]
table at the [ __ ] coffee bean and she
comes up and she's like this is a
handicapped table can I sit here instead
of you and I'm like it's not a
handicapped table it's just a [ __ ]
table but of course I was like oh sure I
didn't know and I left you know it's
amazing like I go there but like these
crazy people affect my mood my overall
mood I'm driving to the comedy store
like this [ __ ] almost going to
fight with Billy Idol on meth I mean
we're all [ __ ] kind of crazy but like
just these guys broke in I don't know
what at what point do you cross the
[ __ ] excentric line and - oh that
guy's got a real problem whatever dude I
guess maybe you know I've been it you
know what's made me in a [ __ ] good
mood like all week I got these [ __ ]
unreal pants man like I got these
[ __ ] unreal pants to it and I'm this
isn't a bad by the way I know as my fact
I'm not even going to tell you the
[ __ ] brand or whatever I walked into
this store and I got these one pair of
pants man and their jogger their jog
jeans bro they're [ __ ] so ill man
they [ __ ] stretch out around the [ __ ]
area and like the [ __ ] they have no
belt loop but they have the tie and then
they get skinny at the bottom and you
can wear them you could sag them a
little bit and it looks like you know
you got a diaper on but also you're kind
of feeling it like people look at you
and they're like that guy knows what's
up
these pants are so unreal bro and I got
two of them and I wish I got they were
all spaced out around the table I wish I
got all they were like 10 or 11 pair of
different colors I wish I got all the
shades but I got dude I got like acid
wash ones like a [ __ ] and then I also
got white ones like an even bigger
[ __ ] and I wore them dude and I warm
how about when you wear white pants
that's basically like saying hey I'm
gonna wash these I'm gonna wash these
you know I'm gonna wash these later
tonight like you [ __ ] walk in
you you sit down and you there's always
[ __ ] on chairs and tables are you
[ __ ] I got out of my car and the
ankle hit the [ __ ] bottom of the car
pants over pants over that's it washing
machine here I come
got out of the car with white pants hey
have you got out of the car hey did you
get out of the car with white pants on
washing machine here he here I come did
you go outside washing machine here I
come if you wear white pants you got a
death wish man we got a wash wish I mean
let's not say you want to kill yourself
but girls were white pants all the time
what do they do one time I was and this
is I'm not even trying to be gross I was
at the library when I was in high school
and a teacher was wearing white pants
and she was leaning over the the counter
and she had like this is gross I don't
mean to be gross but she had she had
gotten her period and it was all over
her white pants man and she didn't know
and I saw a student walk up and be like
excuse me mrs. yada yada and then she
was like and then she went to the
bathroom shed white pants on hey don't
wear white pants when you're gonna maybe
get your period
dillan then then then I mean that's just
uh beggin fur but anyway I wear these
pants and I got this Irish friend named
mark and he just says unreal pants on
real pants I know I can't really do that
the accent it kind of sounds Indian when
I do it but all those pants are unreal
on real pants and I'm like thanks bro
and I just got you know so now our word
at the moment is unreal that's always
say like my [ __ ] chest feels unreal I
just worked it out and we laugh we
laughed like a bunch of [ __ ] idiots
but these pants dude forget it it's on
you know when you put on certain pants
and you're like it's on if any action
goes down everybody's getting kicked if
anybody talks [ __ ] I'll do a high kick
I'll hit their [ __ ] medulla oblongata
I [ __ ]
take my heel to their medulla oblongata
and knock them out make them feel sense
senseless did you want to feel senseless
talk [ __ ] to me while I'm wearing unreal
pants that's what I'm [ __ ] saying
whatever you guys don't know you don't
know what I'm saying half you guys are
probably like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about but those of you that
truly know what I'm talking about
real babies this is my cult get in on it
get in on it um
get the [ __ ] in on it man the chicken
dance dude imagine if the guy did the
chicken dance in unreal pants I probably
would have posted it to be totally
honest have you guys tried lifts if
you're choosing a ride-sharing company
to drive for go with the company that
treats you better lift
that's lift lifts offers in-app tipping
only lifts when you drive for lyft you
keep a hundred percent of the tips
drivers have been paid over 150 million
tips since the feature was introduced
introduced a hundred and fifty million
dollars in tips hey that's a lot of
money it's almost too much so sign up
with them Express pay let's drivers get
paid almost instantly instead of waiting
for weeks lyft has even taken the
guesswork out of pickups the new amp
device EMP device uses color coding to
help passengers find their drivers you
can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus
tips that's a lot of money you want to
make more money drive more it's never
been easier to give yourself a raise
just give your Oh silver raise get in
the car you want make more money open
the car door is it that simple it's that
simple if calm slash Congrats today and
you can get a $500 new driver bonus
that's lift calm / Congrats lift calm /
Congrats limited time only terms apply
and wear your pants when you do it get
on real pants [ __ ] you know I mean
and that's the [ __ ] uh you know it's
funny how like things I was think about
this when I was a kid like toys made you
happy you know like a fire
a truck a little fire truck and then
when you get close for your birthdays
you'd be like ah a shirt tommy sucks
Tommy got me a shirt that his mom picked
out I wanted a [ __ ] ninja turtle
right and then later on like you just
changed completely like if somebody
bought me a ninja turtle now I'd be like
hey man it crazy you can go to coffee
bean with your shirt open the letter on
your face but now I want pants and I
want shirts because I want to look fly
his [ __ ]
extra paper scoop that up dude 1 1 LL
Cool J lyric where he starts in the song
and he goes like this yeah fresh off the
private jet to Europe extra paper scoop
that up held for 14 minutes extra paper
scooped that up my favorite dude extra
paper like leg it was a question
extra paper hey scoop that up scooped
like ah I imagine him leaning out of the
plane and just as it [ __ ] touches
down putting his arm down and scooping
it up like Arnold Schwarzenegger when he
[ __ ] tilts the car in last action
hero in the diet and catches the
dynamite and then throws it out of the
car extra dynamite scoop the extra
dynamite scoop that up yeah worst on the
Schwarzenegger impression of all time um
extra paper scoop that up saqqaq LL Cool
J is the [ __ ] though he really is when I
did lip-sync battle he was so [ __ ]
funny he was like mr. showman and he was
like so dope and he was like man you
hilarious dog ha and then during the
commercial break one time he was like he
oh let's just get this over with but
like still ha ha ha but like still doing
it like in his like showmanship thing he
was like you know say let's get let's
get home no ha ha it was so funny and I
laughed so hard he was like you know
what I mean all right now's like yep
then saying Demi Lovato well didn't sing
[ __ ] actually um oh man dude I look cool
J is what looks better than me
and he
90 no how old is he for real he's like
40-something he's got to be almost 50
guys been around forever and he looks
way better than me extra chicks could
scoop that up and me look like as Bryan
Callen says an Albanian sex trafficker
um yeah I do though I look like a
[ __ ] I look like I look like a creepy
dad somebody said I was my buddy my
opener said like you you're like the dad
of our group and that [ __ ] is not
that didn't I'm like is that cool
Emma is that sexy that I'm the dad like
it's kind of cool if girls are like hey
daddy
but like if your [ __ ] friend says
you're like the dad of the group
instantly dried up all the [ __ ] made
boners go down you know for the gays or
whatever I want gays to think I'm
[ __ ] sexy though some guys are
homophobic about that [ __ ] and they're
like nah bro that ain't cool [ __ ] that
man one time a guy I don't know if he
was gay or not I assumed he was but he
came up to me he was like just so you
know the gay community loves you and I
was like [ __ ] man that [ __ ] made my
whole week it made me feel like it made
me feel accepted you know it was very
cool I liked it it was nice for him to
say that to was like one of the nicest
compliments I forgot um you know not
that there's like a whole [ __ ]
meeting on it like hey guys we're here
how what do we think about Chris D'Elia
I'm gonna thing of it when you guys came
to party oh we liked him
oh cool sir Punch Boogie Nights Lee no
man windows came to a party what do we
feel about Chris D'Elia as a hall we
support him tell um go ahead go ahead
Rick go to a show and tell um um but
yeah made me feel good Mimmi feel cept
it everybody wants to feel sap did right
why is everybody want to feel cept it
dude when I was in Toronto for five
weeks I was alone ish you know I didn't
like everyone else was
working when I wasn't working and then I
I didn't really have many friends there
I had one buddy but besides him I felt
lonely and I started thinking about when
guys are in prison and then they got to
go to the hole they're not septic
they're [ __ ] in the hole
dude that I literally felt like my brain
was turning to mush because I wasn't
hanging out with enough people dude
imagine if you were alone on an island
not cept it buy anything but sand and
twigs yeah that's that that just would
rock my world man I used to think like
[ __ ] that it would be cool like to be
literally I used to be like did if you
were alone on an island to be sad but
like I would just be [ __ ] I'd be an
animal man I'd hunt animals [ __ ] trees
you know what I mean like I'd find like
the appeal in like beautiful trees and
just carve a hole out and just [ __ ] them
and like then while I when I'm done
[ __ ] a tree I just run over to a boar
and just attack it and maybe it would
get the best of me but maybe not though
it would you know maybe wouldn't maybe I
would rear naked choke hold the [ __ ]
boar and then just fire it up and eat it
and eat some and then [ __ ] a tree and go
to bed you know probably lonely though
[ __ ] trees and eatin boar but then
when I went to Toronto I was like man I
only have one friend here I don't think
I would I think I would [ __ ] just let
the bori me now that I really feel now
that I really uh you know really know I
really know what it feels like oh [ __ ]
it's so goddamn hot in this room and I'm
wearing a sweater and I knew you know
when you [ __ ] do that [ __ ] when
you're like should I wear a sweater or
not you're like it's cold out but I'm
gonna be inside most of the time and
then you but the sweater looks like bomb
like you look like ill is [ __ ] and
you're like this is my outfit though and
then you're out and then your armpits
start sweating you're like I knew I
should have picked a different outfit
because I don't look trill if I take the
[ __ ] sweater off and just wear the
undershirt the undershirt is and what's
trill the sweaters what's trill right so
I'm not that I need to look trill this
is an audio podcast but like you know I
like the sweater but like man I got to
wash this undershirt now
but you know it's like life and times
man trials and tribulations
speaking of unreal pants have you guys
heard of this company five four it's a
great company for clothing and it
doesn't cost a fortune five four Club is
revolutionizing the way men shop and
it's true to each month they send you a
curated box of to three items that they
are hand-picked to match the current
season and your style they've been
helping men with fashion for over 15
years and shipped over 100,000 men every
month they know what they're doing so if
you don't you know that's fine because
they're doing it they sent me a bunch of
stuff that I actually love and one of
the one or two of the shirts are
unbelievable and I wear I've wore them
like days in a row to where people are
like yo bro you know do you wash that
shirt because it's great
so whatever when you look at you feel
good so so do that you get 120 dollars
worth of clothes for just $60 a month
and you can pause or cancel anytime and
as a member
oh here's another thing as a 5-4 club
member you also receive up to 50% off
items in their online shop and access to
exclusive Members Only items free
shipping and size exchanges Chris Paul
and Mark Wahlberg use five for club and
they're very cool you don't like them
you probably a plant five four is
featured in GQ bison in style I mean
it's just great go to five four club
calm right now and enter promo code
congrats and they'll give you 50% off
your first month's package plus a free
pair of sunglasses that's 50% off your
first package at five for club spelled
five-0 you are club.com promo code
Congrats five for club comm promo code
Congrats milk and yob milking you up you
know I really am you know I know some I
know some people are like all
commercials but hooking yeah I'm telling
you what to do with your life so you
don't have to spend all the time to do
it you understand it's easy and also
you're going to be part of my cult come
on guys get with it there's
rules here alright you want look cool
you want be cool alright you got do the
what you got do we get dough so what's
up um did you guys watch the Indy 500 by
the way uh I think it was recently
because I saw some [ __ ] on it and
there's not something I get less than
that Indy 500 400 million people show up
at a racetrack and sit and watch cars
drive around a loop and you can't see
the goddamn cars because you're too far
away and you cheer and it's hours and
hours and nothing changes they just kind
of over and go over and over again be in
the lead the whole time and then you're
just watching ah I get that it is
endeared towards me I'm a Cali guy and I
was born in New Jersey and definitely
definitely a southern thing I feel like
the Indy 500 is Indy 500 mean that they
go around the track five hundred times
in deef yeah I think it does right uh
i'ma look it up it they go 500 time they
go the average speed is 166 miles per
hour slay thil um it's just insane
practice looks look at some of this to
practice Marco Andretti won I guess 2016
wonder if there's like a talent that you
have to have or if it's just you you
trot you keep practice and we gotta have
some kind of countdown I guess 500 times
a doing anything 500 times it's too much
in a row you do something 500 times in a
row you Christ you do something 500
times in a row you're the guy who does
the chicken dance that would be the best
Indy 500 I would
if he was driving a car with his dog in
the passenger seat smellin like [ __ ]
just driving by chicken dance
every time he goes by I don't understand
Indy 500 I don't understand the appeal I
don't understand the appeal now that's
coming from a guy who doesn't understand
the look I don't like watching
basketball or football or baseball but I
understand the appeal but I don't
understand the appeal of going to the
Indy 500 unless it's like everyone's
going let's go but if it's like no we
got to go because we want to see the
tide car ah what no that's weird to me I
mean I don't know
I'm sure I'm pissing off a plethora of
Southern's but don't care but that's
coming from you know I know I said I
don't I know people sometimes in the
party from the pockets it like you don't
like a lot of things man it's not that I
don't like a lot of things it's that I
just think it's funny and like that's
what I talk about because comedian but
also I like I like some things too and I
talk about them too like those unreal
pants dude really you don't want to hear
you don't want to [ __ ] tune into the
podcast to somebody just have somebody
being really passionate about [ __ ] they
like it real bad would be real bad right
I don't know I mean I don't know I'm
just doing this by the [ __ ] seat of
my phone flying by the seat of my pants
dude this is episode 20 and I'm still
figuring it out but you guys [ __ ] you
guys keeping me going last last podcast
we had the most downloads we got so
moving on up and I didn't the thing I
thought last episode was maybe one of
the ones that lacked so good so new
people heard that and then thought I'll
[ __ ] this guy no but it's good whatever
I don't know I mean I know there's a
difference between I just feel like if
you like everything you're kind of
you know that guy that's like oh yeah I
wanna I wanna I want to experience
everything that life has to offer that
this world has to offer you know like
that guy or a girl
is just like and then they just are
fascinated with everything that that
person is like piece of [ __ ] you know
because like well then who are you if
you don't like some things I trust
somebody that doesn't like a lot of [ __ ]
way more than somebody who likes too
many things I got a buddy that travels
everywhere duties in Hawaii right now
and he sent me a video of him snorkeling
and [ __ ]
fish beaten him in the [ __ ] face
tortoise sawed tortoise or turtle
whatever and he's like isn't it amazing
and like yeah but it's kind of amazing
for me to watch the video also right
like we got [ __ ] I gotta watch this
tortoise I get to watch it not only in
real life I get to watch it on the
little handheld device in my [ __ ]
hand at the coffee bean uh what that's
also actually more amazing oh yeah but
you got to get out there and experience
it like you've seen in Good Will Hunting
when he was like sure you know a lot
about the Sistine Chapel but you never
been there you don't know the way it is
and yadda-yadda you've read all about it
but you don't when Robin Williams is
talking to Matt Damon when I was
watching that movie I was like that's
the same [ __ ] thing it's the same
[ __ ] thing if all we have is words to
[ __ ] describe the [ __ ] to tell people
about it then that's what the [ __ ]
happening to us when we're not there
people are describing it to us so we
just [ __ ] use those same words
not everybody can experience it so ah
you know I just like anybody who likes
everything or if everybody likes
something the thing is not good I feel
like you got to be polarizing a little
bit and also you can't like everything
you like everything you faker
you liar there's a lot of actors that go
on there just like oh the movie was
amazing and I had such an amazing time
and how amazing is Elijah Wood and how
amazed
Jennifer Garner and it was just amazing
and everything was just so amazing no
you didn't get along with some of those
people and also the movie might suck I
would hate to have to do press on a
movie that I hated though I think I've
ever done that it'll be very hard for me
to lie but I guess I would because it
has to help other people you gotta you
can't you don't wanna [ __ ] bury other
people in their work you know you gotta
find a balance though just look at me
and I'm doing a junket on a movie I did
that I don't like just look at me if I'm
winking you know what's up yeah I had a
great time wink
yeah no no it was great working with the
director going it was a very cohesive
set
and the script really really uh
I thought it was great but then when we
started shooting it I realized wow this
is actually amazing
that's wink that's the wink but knowing
if I'm going in space to shed oh dude
10-minute podcast fans when I used to do
that podcast you're gonna like this next
[ __ ] promo what do you do when you
want to snack but all you can find is
junk food rely on your self-control to
resist the temptation please
you eat the junk food so start snacking
healthy with nature box that's nature
box nature box makes snacks that
actually taste great and are better for
you created with high-quality
ingredients that are free from
artificial colors flavors or sweeteners
so you can feel great about snack and
dude they sent me a bunch of stuff ate
them all in one day so good i I just
love snacks and I feel like if you're
like me you like snacks okay and also if
your person you like snacks because but
you keep around the junk food you do
that because it's easy but they'll send
this to you
my-my-my I got uh the the whole-wheat
strawberry Figgy bars forget it the
peanut butter nom noms
forget it put them all in my face I'll
swallow them become part of me naturebox
they made their service better you can
order as much as you want as often as
you want with no minimum purchase
required and you can cancel anytime so
go to naturebox calm and check out their
snack catalogue there are over 100
snacks to choose from and they're
constantly adding delicious new snacks
there's a good choose the snacks you
want they'll deliver them right to your
door with nature box you'll never get
bored ok if you don't like and here's
the other thing too and there are there
new strategies mine's inspired by real
customer feedback and if you ever try
snack you don't like nature box will
replace it for free ok right now you'll
save even more nature boxes offering our
fans 50% off your first order
when you go to nature box comrades
that's naturebox.com/tyler Congrats or
50% your fur off your first order nature
box common grats nature box Square cash
square cash is the best way to pay
people back so do it do it Tupac would
have done it if to buck was alive today
he would have used Square cash you like
Tupac you stand for beliefs then get
Square cash setting a routine receiving
money is totally easy you download the
square cash app in your link you link to
your debit or your credit card selected
amount to send and you type in a
friend's phone number or email address
to complete a payment and they get a
notification that they just received the
money that's it no gimmicks Square cash
is better than the other guys this isn't
a social network you know they don't
post people like all you you sent $25 to
[ __ ] Rick X nobody knows it's secret
it's on the download it's on the
down-low if you need to pay if you need
to pay a hooker use square cash
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now now will they get mad
at me for saying you could pay hookers
with square cash probably but I don't
care because I have to keep it real with
you babies um that's what you'll get
you'll get 100% keeping it real when
you're here with here when you're here
with me listening to congratulations
you won't get other maybe if I got to do
a junket for a movie you might be
getting the knock to keepin it real but
here you'll be getting the keeping it
real
deluxe home edition crystally a set
that's what
be getting okay it's just how it is I'm
in a lonely room right now
that's me keeping it real I'm in my
podcast room I got some [ __ ] sound
what do you call it
those little waffle sound acceptors the
[ __ ] you keep talking about them will
you [ __ ] you call them I got a bunch of
frames with some pictures and frames
they're not hung up they're just on the
floor says sad I have a TV not hung up
and orange I have two orange chairs my
producer is not here because he said he
couldn't come one fire um but you know
Pam I pay him a percentage didn't show
up not professional one fire um but whoa
right the paint's coming off of the wall
because I tried put tape on it and then
it [ __ ] came down looks like a piece
of [ __ ] you know I got a puppet of me in
here that I had on undateable wasn't
supposed to take it home
stole it legitimately the [ __ ] are they
gonna use it for though you know prop
guys are cool when you're on this TV set
they'll be like hey here you go
I heard you like vodka you know they got
cool okay you go you know like oh do you
need this for the show they're like
nobody needs to know every prop guy is
like a [ __ ] somebody Tony Soprano
would hire hey you like that you like
this yeah you like this watch take it
nobody needs to know take the watch we
get two of them and then you're like
blinged out because of the prop guy you
feel me
um but yeah so it's funny the stuff that
you get when you're an actor or a
comedian like the stuff that people send
you and this stuff like I got a
literally no clue absolutely no [ __ ]
clue laughs factory hits me up in the
email hey you got a package delivered
for you do you hear when can you come by
and get it so it's like I'll get it when
I do my show there and whatever was one
Friday I get there there's a big box for
me and I said what the [ __ ] is it and
the owner Jamie Masada was like we'll be
careful opening it what a [ __ ]
there's some anthrax pops out you know
or like there's a bomb
and I'm like [ __ ] good I actually
honestly good so I got my opener to open
it
and I stood well far far away because I
he's gonna I want him to die of anthrax
not me
I'd much rather him die of anthrax than
me and so he opened it up and I crept
forward like easy easy non up just in
case they were [ __ ] you know rats with
the Ebola virus or whatever the [ __ ] and
I looked and there are about 20 coffee
mugs cups like 20 coffee cups with
[ __ ] Boeing with a picture of a
Boeing aircraft on it flying through the
sky oh why what on earth did I ever do
to make somebody send me 20 coffee mugs
with Boeing aircrafts flying through the
air on them
what the [ __ ] who sent me that [ __ ] I
literally have no clue who sent me that
[ __ ] but now they're mine they're in the
back of my car haven't used them yet
because I have coffee cups but who sent
me that [ __ ] as an actor as a comedian
when you have a fanbase you get sent the
weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] got sent a dead
cat once no I'm kidding that never
happened but that would be [ __ ]
amazing please don't ever send me a dead
cat anyone but yeah if you do want to
send me stuff send it to the Comedy
Store The Laugh Factory though but don't
send me don't send me 20 coffee cups
with Boeing aircrafts flying through the
sky a very weird maybe because they know
I like coffee or somebody know who was
from there was no note or anything but
they [ __ ] it up maybe they [ __ ] it
up my agents by the way because they
knew I was sick so I'm taking a shower
today ding dong ding dong my doorbells
ringing ding dong ding dong ding dong
with doorbells ringing I say I look out
I use the intercom I literally go who is
it they're like GrubHub it's a [ __ ]
food service thing that I don't use so
it's like yeah and they're like yeah you
placed an order I was like nah I don't
have any food comment and they're like
Oh leave ding dong ding dong later I'm
with this [ __ ]
I don't even check answer this time
because who the [ __ ] ringing the door
who rings a doorbell honestly only
somebody you don't want to talk to the
only people that the only people that
show up that your house that you
actually want to be there they'll text
you that you're there
doorbells are [ __ ] obsolete and also
you want the people that don't use the
doorbells to use
you don't want them to tax you want them
to use the doorbell you want them to be
like dingdong I'm here and they're like
I text you four times you're like we're
forgetting the turtle [ __ ] tell
people I ring the doorbell or people
that know they shouldn't be there that
feel a little uncomfortable because
they're like well it's very formal I
gotta ring the doorbell so this [ __ ]
guy is there dingdong dingdong again and
I'm like it can't be the same guy so I
look I go on my balcony I look over and
I say hey man what's up and he says hey
GrubHub is here for you and I said I'm
telling you man
I didn't order GrubHub and he says you
are you Chris and I'm like huh yeah so I
go down to check the address he
addresses right and it says chicken soup
I'm like oh I actually kind of want
chicken soup because I'm sick so that's
cool so I take it I bring it up and I
open it up and I'm like I don't know who
the [ __ ] and did they poison it like I
don't know who the [ __ ] so I open it up
not only is it not chicken soup it's a
bagel with cream cheese and salmon in it
gross gag me gargle my nuts gross his
[ __ ] and a [ __ ] like beef sandwich
gross why would I eat a beef sandwich
and a bagel with salmon and cream cheese
in it and I was like who the [ __ ] sent
me this I don't know who's sending me
all this [ __ ] first of all nobody knows
where I live it's an I just moved you
know and like nobody knows my trust
nobody's been over I don't give my
address out so I [ __ ] call the number
so finally I checked my email later and
my agent sends me an email hey man my
agent's assistant heard you were sick I
know you were sick because I cancelled
the [ __ ] appointment so we sent you
some chicken soup
and I was like I don't want telling I
have that hard to tell that the [ __ ]
order was wrong like all you guys are
awesome thanks so much
but how annoying is all that [ __ ] I'm
sick I don't want to [ __ ] go
downstairs and open the doorbell
all the windows lay my bed this guy
thing dong ding dong keep something I
didn't order some [ __ ] gives me some
chicken soup I'm like all cool you know
what I would actually eat this [ __ ] and
it's a [ __ ] beefs and wasn't even
like it was the most regular beef ever
you know like sometimes it's like ham or
like you know
um like what else is is like roast beef
or like some [ __ ] where you're like okay
yeah nice this was like the most regular
ass my little kitchen beef that you'd
see like where like kids would be like
playing house in like a little stove and
be like here's your beef and they put it
on like a blue plate maybe like um to
the kid and you'd think beef doesn't
even look like this and it was stacked
it was stacked the sandwich was stacked
so gross and cream cheese with fish in
it buy on a bagel buy and fries what
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] is eating this
[ __ ] you know who ate this [ __ ] the guy
who died in seven from gluttony that's
who's eating it the fat guy have
facedown in a bowl of porridge naked
when Brad Pitt [ __ ] discover some
with Morgan Freeman hey my crystal ear
or my the fat guy who's naked with the
face down in a cup of porridge
while Brad Brad Pitt and Morgan Freeman
disgust discovers him in the first act
in seven which one am I
me not that guy so don't send me a beef
sandwich stacked to the gills with
[ __ ] in everything bagel with salmon
and cream cheese in it and fries fat
steak fries too you know so not my
friend
they [ __ ] said sent you some chicken
soup and then they just wanted me to
[ __ ] eat that [ __ ] not also who
uses GrubHub I feel like post mates is
the thing that's probably they [ __ ] it
up how about when they send you your
order and it's completely [ __ ] up and
there's nothing you can do about it just
completely wrong one time I order like a
full like a sandwich and a milkshake or
some [ __ ] and they sent me a [ __ ]
side salad it was just salad no not
solid it was green leaves with carrots
on it that's it and you know what man I
[ __ ] ate that [ __ ] so angrily - I was
so hungry
oh my [ __ ] John based ow
you ever see the John based on you guys
know John bass now is the guy who does
the abs she's always standing like
twisted with his arm on his hip it's so
funny uh I don't know you know
I think I'm about to wrap this up you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna look at
the [ __ ] hashtags here thanks for
listening you guys this was a rough one
because I was sick honestly and I was
just you know what dude somebody's
asking me here at tosh.dough make dumb
an Inc what the [ __ ] do mi n en qu e
Dominic clay had change it have less
letters in there I feel like anyway uh
she looks like a nice girl nice lady but
definitely expected you to post a pic of
the Amber Rose challenge what were your
thoughts on that here's what I don't
know what that is here are my thoughts
on it enough with the [ __ ] challenges
they're not challenges anymore
they're just [ __ ] you know like what
I'm a my specials coming out man on fire
what am I supposed to do hey guys let
yourself on fire the man on fire
challenge and that gross
what is the
rose challenge they tryna uh oh I guess
it's is it naked chicks or something oh
it's like people being naked on I mean
you know so like I love how she's like
it's so funny to like she's like trying
to get people to like celebrate their
bodies and [ __ ] and like be amazing and
like showing their tits and [ __ ] and
stuff and it's like yeah that works for
Amber Rose she literally got famous for
dating Kanye West that's who does that
but if you're a [ __ ] girl that has
like a [ __ ] that works out like Rolex
and all of a sudden you post on Twitter
you naked [ __ ] and tits you're getting
fired hey hey how about the fired
challenge hey amber Rose good Anya way
to inspire females to go out there and
post naked pictures of their [ __ ] and
tits they're gonna get fired
you're not cuz you're famous for dating
rappers I'm not saying I'd look I know
nothing about I'm amber awesome
maybe she's great so I am talking out of
my [ __ ] ass but don't post picture
you bit some pieces on Instagram you're
gonna get fired you got stuff to lose so
if that's what that is but enough with
the challenges people are just
challenging everything a man
um hey it's the breathing challenge how
much breath can you take before you pass
out people just passing out on the
[ __ ] sidewalk just opening their
skulls
oh he failed he died this is for ALS
[Music]
number one celebrity crush female and
male Meredith Eriksen at mayor
underscore Barrow five change it
naturally you knew I'd say it celebrity
crush female is Kate Beckinsale no it's
gal gadot for sure if you're if you're a
guy and you're heterosexual and you
don't even if you're gay and you don't
want to be in a room with gal gadot
you're in you're in an alien suit you're
any a human suit as an alien that girl's
amazing um
mail man I got a lot of dude crushes you
know what bothers me too is when people
post MCM man crush them up whatever and
it's a girl your guys are supposed to do
man crush Mondays that's for guys to do
if you're a girl you don't have a man
crush you just have a crush
you're being redundant my guy crushes
I got a few man liam neeson for sure um
oh you know for sure is the Chris
Hemsworth 100% he could get it um I like
those guys um I
those guys let's see another one of
these gaming the systems people send me
sometimes pictures of people check this
out look at this [ __ ] and they're
just dressed regular I don't understand
uh do you ever use pickup lines or have
you had them used on you at AFC lover no
I never have and never have I don't know
not really lot lines no not only anybody
really does that I was watching a movie
the other day and what was it oh his
species and the guy on it said I was
just wondering he walked up over to two
ladies and he was like I was just
wondering how two beautiful ladies are
standing here with no dates and it's
like imagine if he said that in real
life what a [ __ ] bag of [ __ ] you
would be imagine saying that going to up
to two ladies you know what there you go
that's the crystal Leah challenge woke
up to one or two ladies that are alone
and say I was just over there wondering
how a lady like you or how you two
beautiful ladies we're standing here
with no date date you know that's what
he said
and then of course it didn't work out in
the movie which it wouldn't work out in
real life too I wonder I would I would
love to try that if I walked up to a
girl hey excuse me I was just wondering
uh what a beautiful lady like you was
doing without it without a without a
date I mean that would be I would feel
so [ __ ] saying that it would feel so
insecure saying that I don't really feel
insecure usually because I've [ __ ]
bond a lot um this guy says at stars av
how about white people just stop saying
the n-word at all and there won't and
there will be no outrage joke or not he
doesn't get a pass I guess we're talking
about well Bill Maher yeah I mean the
guy has a good point
I mean I don't say it even in jokes but
you know it is on the other hand you
know that's bill maher was making a joke
he is a comedian I don't know if there's
two points to it I understand there's
more than two points but let's see uh-oh
this is a good one Reese Randall at or
or at all Randall 10 thoughts on people
who clap on a plane lands so annoying
yeah that is stupid the guy just did his
job
I don't clap at anything though unless
it's like a real live performance that
[ __ ] is amazing or like a comedian
that made me laugh but but like because
that adds to the live performance but
when you're on a plane and you land
you're not in the live performance
you're in the [ __ ] Airbus and they
did their job
so don't clap but you know that it's
like clapping in movies
hey Jim Carrey isn't really here okay so
stop clapping at the mask um and I loved
the masks hmm all right one morning I'm
out of here I mean what's the most
embarrassing thing to ever happen to you
this person Lexi Serna I don't even know
how to answer that one time I [ __ ] my
pants as I had a sleepover when I was uh
I got it must have been ten I was too
scared to go to the bathroom because
[ __ ] Freddy Krueger was on TV and my
buddy already fell asleep and I was like
I'll just go to I'll just I'll just go
to sleep and now go to the bathroom I
wake up go to the bathroom when it's
light out and I woke up and I [ __ ]
had [ __ ] my pants uh I was nine so I
don't know man
why did I mean why am I even telling you
guys this Freddy Krueger who scared the
[ __ ] out of me when I was a kid uh all
right well that's it there you go there
you have it mmm
uh all right so that's it yeah I'm sorry
guys but I'm done why we went over an
hour that was good that was a struggle
because I was sick I wasn't feeling good
and so you know what you guys you guys
stuck with me through this one and I
really appreciate that if you're still
listening now you baby you're true baby
don't tell the others Square cash
don't forget square cash you're using
that yet download the free square cash
app for iOS or Android do it now my
upcoming dates you heard about them in
the beginning Baltimore West Palm Beach
Huntington New York Albuquerque New
Mexico West I said West Palm Beach and
Austin Texas Nashville Tennessee Salt
Lake City Phoenix Tempe Irvine
California Spokane so go get tickets at
Crystal e-comm on that and tweet me at
hashtag congratulations pod and don't
forget to put this in your queue my
Netflix special my Netflix special
coming out man on fire June 27 rate and
review this show congratulations on
iTunes Google Play and stitcher that
would help me out would really
appreciate that trying to game the
system and trying to back up the
[ __ ] Brinks truck you want to
help me out
Thanks see you babies
[Music]